lo que intentaremos entender en este
vídeo es la balanza de pagos balanza de
pagos ahora qué es la balanza de pagos
lo que es es una cuenta que registra
todas todas las transacciones monetarias
entre un país y el resto del mundo eso
es la balanza de pagos son pagos que se
hacen para dentro del país o pagos que
se hacen fuera del país ahora que tengo
yo información para eeuu en el año 2011
estos números en esta columna de aquí
están todo en dólares ahora aquí en
verde en verde tengo las razones por las
que pagos se harían dentro del país ya
sean pagos para el gobierno pagos para
personas en particular o ya sea para
reserva federal entonces por ejemplo si
yo vivo en eeuu y mis padres viven en
mexico y yo les quiero mandar dinero esa
transferencia de dinero quedaría
registrada en las razones de color
naranja ahora en este vídeo yo primero
me quiero enfocar en lo que es el lado
izquierdo en estas razones de aquí a las
cuales se les conoce como cuenta
corriente la cuenta corriente lo que
hace es enfocarse en cosas como
intercambios así que en exportaciones
importaciones se enfoca en cosas
con ingresos en un periodo de tiempo
ahora la cuenta corriente lo que hace
básicamente es recoger las operaciones
reales de bienes y servicios y rentas
que se producen entre los residentes de
un país y el resto del mundo en un
periodo de tiempo claro así que bueno es
esa cuenta corriente es una cuenta
corriente y en el próximo vídeo nos
enfocaremos en lo que es la cuenta
capital la cuenta capital y lo que hace
la cuenta capital es reflejar un cambio
neto en la propiedad nacional de activos
lo que quiero decir es que asientan las
compras y ventas de activos ejemplo
acciones bonos y tierras pero bueno eso
lo veremos en el próximo vídeo ahora hay
que enfocarnos en la cuenta corriente y
como dije en verde tengo las razones por
las que eeuu recibió pagos del resto del
mundo en el año 2011 aquí el primero que
tenemos es exportaciones y este dato
está en billones de dólares son 2 mil
105 billones o lo que es lo mismo 2.1
trillones de dólares y si estamos
exportando 2.1 trillones de dólares
valor en bienes y servicios entonces el
resto del mundo tendrá que pagar ese
dinero a eeuu
y esos dos puntos 1 trillones serán un
pago es un ingreso al país básicamente
la razón principal por la que el país
tiene más dinero después de todas las
transacciones de dinero que se hacen ya
sean pagos a ciudadanos privados o al
gobierno oa la reserva federal aunque
por lo general son pagos a ciudadanos
privados oa corporaciones ahora
siguiente los recibos de ingresos son
ingresos que reciben los americanos por
poseer activos en el extranjero entonces
se imagina que yo soy una ciudadana
americana y tengo departamentos en
italia supongamos así que me deben pagar
renta a los que viven ahí y luego yo
convierto ese dinero que me pagaron de
renta a dólares y los regreso a eeuu ese
sería un recibo de ingresos para mí y
bueno esas son las principales razones
por las que pago se hace en eeuu son las
razones en verde ahora por otro lado
también tenemos a países que le venden
productos a eeuu entonces aquí tenemos
importaciones importaciones y de hecho
este es un país que tiene déficit de
importación hace más importaciones que
exportaciones como tú puedes observar
aquí aproximadamente 2.7 trillones de
dólar
en el año 2011 entonces cuando este país
está comprando a otros países bienes y
servicios este debe pagarles la moneda
va en la otra dirección la moneda va
hacia otros países ahora los pagos de
ingresos es el otro lado de recibo de
pagos
aquí tenemos a los extranjeros dueños de
activos en el país si un extranjero es
dueño de una pizzería supongamos en eeuu
y el dueño de esa pic sería ganar
supongamos que no sé cien mil dólares al
año
entonces ese dinero irá a él será un
pago de ingresos aquí tenemos este valor
son los ingresos de activistas
extranjeros no van a un americano ni al
gobierno americano ni a una corporación
americana este dinero le pertenece a
alguien fuera del país y por último
tenemos aquí a las transferencias netas
las transferencias netas aquí están que
son básicamente eeuu dando dinero al
resto del mundo entonces por ejemplo
antes observa este dato aquí tenemos 135
billones de dólares que eeuu del resto
del mundo y no estoy hablando de
transacciones como te decía el inicio
del vídeo
si yo soy una ciudadana americana y le
mando dinero a mi mamá que vive en
méxico esto aplica también aplicaría
eeuu dando dinero a otro país
eeuu da más de lo que recibe y eso lo
podemos ver en las transferencias netas
aquí está el datos 135 billones
ahora bien basándonos en lo que tenemos
aquí simplemente en estas causas
las exportaciones recibos de ingresos
transferencias netas etcétera eeuu está
transfiriendo más dinero al extranjero o
recibiendo dinero del extranjero hay que
ver qué está pasando que es más que es
menos así que sacar a la calculadora
aquí está la calculadora muy bien
entonces pensemos aquí tenemos todo el
dinero que el país gana son los ingresos
para eeuu hay que sumarlos entonces
tenemos aquí dos mil 105 más
739 y ahora también hay que restar los
las salidas la salida los pagos que hace
eeuu entonces menos las salidas que son
estas menos las importaciones que son
dos mil 665 de importaciones menos dos
mil 665 de importaciones y menos los 518
billones por los activistas extranjeros
que tienen negocios en el país así que
menos 518 y menos las transferencias
netas que son menos 135 menos menos 135
por las transferencias netas es igual a
menos 474 billones como tú puedes ver es
un país con déficit por cuenta corriente
por estas causas de aquí hay más pagos
hay más salidas en eeuu que ingresos
entonces como puedes ver pago 474
billones en el 2011 entonces tuvo
déficit por cuenta corriente lo voy a
poner aquí el país eeuu tuvo déficit
déficit por cuenta corriente déficit por
cuenta corriente de alvin del número 404
74 millones 474 millones y si ese número
fuera positivo es llamado superávit de
la cuenta corriente superávit de la
cuenta corriente